When will Lord Sarver and your master of basketball operations be arriving?
They have entrusted me as emissary. Now what is this trade?
Trade? No
We’ve come to discuss an alliance
An alliance?
How would that even work?
Think of it more as a merger
Individually, our houses are weak
but together, we can dominate the West as House Kings Suns!
[Triumphant Horn]
Eh...don’t love it
But hold on. But what if I told you you
could play alongside the next Steph Curry?
[Laughter]
Right. It’s just the name “Kings Suns.” It’s awkward
What about Sun Kings?
OK fine, from here on we are House Sun Kings, OK?
We are the Sun Kings
[Triumphant Horn]
We’ve taken the liberty of drafting a standard for our new combined house
Buddy!
Flip it one more
I can’t really see the sun
What do y--It’s in the front of the crown!
Uh, excuse me
I was thinking maybe…I was thinking maybe a crown inside a sun?
Ooh like a fiery crown. I like that.
Thanks yeah, I like to paint so…I think about like compositions and stuff
I think it’s great. We want that. The flaming crown
Oh come on! Buddy and Bogdan spent like three practices stitching this together!
It’s fine, it’s fine, my lord.
It is a small price to pay for a dragon
Dragon?
Yes.  Everyone is actually quite keen to have a look
You mean Dragan?
Huh?
I mean, here he is
That’s a bit of a shit dragon
Where’s its wings?
And scales?!
I’m still developing you guys, come on
Oh I see, so the dragon is actually a person
Great job researching, Vlade, really good researching there
I didn’t realize–I just read the notes the scouts gave me, they said dragon
Did you draft De'Aaron Fox because you thought he was a fox?
Foxes are smart
Ugh God. It’s fine, it’s fine
We can evaluate all our assets when we join forces in Sacramento!
You mean in Phoenicia
Oh for heaven sakes! We just built a state-of-the-art castle
Isn’t Sacramento a bit small?
You want us to go to Phoenicia when It’s a hundred
and f--king twenty degrees every day?!
It gets cool at night
And besides, do you expect us to abandon a city with such a rich basketball history?
Well clearly you are not familiar with the rich history of House Kings
Lord Commander Adelman and his
Adelman
...corner offense?
Oh come on, they don’t even compare to D’Antoni’s Seven Seconds or Less offense!
What are you talking? We had Chris Webber!
Ser Charles was better
That’s ridiculous, man, Webber was bigger, he was more athletic, not even close, man
And you had nothing like Peja Stojakovic
He was no Dan Majerle
All right this guy doesn’t know what he’s talking about with Dan Majerle
Dan Majerle was trash, man
And I suppose you’re going to say the same of Steve Nash!
The Kings have never come close to talent like that
What about the White Knight of Chocolate?
Wait, wait, wait. Did you just compare Jason Williams to Steve Nash?
Have you gone mental?
Well Steve Nash never did an elbow pass
Who gives a shit?
What do you know about passing, ball hog?
All right, enough, enough!
Maybe we are a bunch of ball hogs
And maybe it is bloody hot in Phoenicia
And sure Sacramento’s...
smaller than Tucson. I don’t even know where it is to be honest
But if we put aside our differences,
and combine our houses
well then
we still probably wouldn’t make the playoffs but
Oh boy
Wh-When I look around,
I see a bunch of guys who,
I may not know their names, and
they may not be good, but they play
Basketball I think
And...
Eric…make your point
I guess my point is…
Eh…I don’t know, I don’t even wanna be here